今に見てろ絶対自分はサセするぞと第3者
は何人たりともその人を変えることはでき
ません頑張れ
サトお前はできる絶対できる俺がついてる
から大丈夫
だ青木サの人生系哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる
話今回はですねま成功したいという気持ち
はあるけれどもまどうせ自分なんてという
この劣等感が出てきてしまうこの劣等感を
ま卒業してバネに変えていく方法について
教えていただけますでしょう
[音楽]
か俺でも劣等感で成功してきたんだけどね
最初僕を動かしたのは劣等感ですよだって
中卒ね早く社会でて高校中隊だから家柄が
ない学ない金もないそれこそ体力もそれ
ほど最初はあったわけでもない自信もない
もうないないづでしょもっと言うとその
ずっとルーツで言うなら子供の頃貧乏だっ
たまギリの母に感謝してるけれども
いろんな体験をした新聞少年でもあったし
マグマのようなパワーが僕の中には
やっぱりうめいていたよね今に見てろ絶対
自分はサクセスするぞとだそのサクセス
する方法が分からなかっただけであって
サクセスするぞという思いは内側から
ものすごい劣等感も含めてうめいていた
わけじゃんで劣等感って何かって言ったら
やっぱ葛藤でしょ理想の自分に対してそう
慣れていない自分貧乏だとか無学歴だとか
全部典的に学んだよなアメリカに20何回
も研修受けに行ったりいろんなことした
まあ振り返ってみたら人はその人が考えて
いる通りの人間になると僕は劣等感で
トップセルスマンになり劣等感で
成り上がったわけよね最初プロセルスの
世界でどのぐらい劣等感強かったかって
言うとすごかったと思うよだってそれが
ファッションに出てたもんね白のスーツに
赤のあざみのネクタイとかさコンビの靴で
あれで黒の目がかけたら昔だ安しみたいな
ねお笑いみたいな世界ですよ白のスーツで
ルイビトンの皮持って歩くってさちょっと
変わってる姿だよねなんかそういうどうだ
みたいなもんじゃんどうだどうだみたいな
これでもかってぐらい自己主張してるだ
から実は劣等感の強い人間って自己主張が
めちゃ強くなるんですよ本当に健全な自己
概念持つともう自己主張しなくてもいい
自然体になるんだよね今の私は自然体です
よだから若い時はやっぱり持ち物で自分の
劣等感カバーしようとしたし成績で自分の
自己概念の低さをカバーしようとしたしま
でも事実実績を出して達成をしていく中で
自己概念上がって言ったような事実だて
認められるわけだからでも深いところでの
自己承認ができたっていうのは29歳で
バイブルと出会った時ですよねそれまでの
僕は駆り立てられていただからいくら
タイトルを取ってもま私の言葉で言うと
アチーブメントピラミッドの目標から上だ
から達成しても達成しても勝ち負けなので
また張なきゃいけないでもピラミッドの
土台人生理念がありビジョンがありそっ
から目標計画日の実践の一貫性ってやつだ
よねの土台が明確になって愛が入った時に
愛とは何かっていうテーマになるわけだよ
でこの愛を土台にした真の成功者になると
考えた時にマネメダルを追わなくても
ミッションメッセージを追求する人生に変
変わったてことだよねだ劣等感は若い時に
はあったけれども工学納税者になってから
は全く劣等感なくなりましたいやこれ
めっちゃ大事センクアグロー
リッチthinkアビカムリッチ絶対に
経済的に豊かになって納税しなきゃだめ
です納税しかつ社員にも分かち
い社会にもちゃんと貢献してる事業と納税
でそれから社会にも学校作ったり公益財団
を私は作り奨学金を何千万も出してるよね
そうすると俺すごいなって気がついたら
あの17歳で溶接校のま鉄工所の行員から
スタートした僕がまセールスでトップなり
トップマネージャーになり会社でチーフ
トレーナーになり役員になり32歳で創業
して社員5名賞金500万だったけど今
会社そのものも200億の価値の会社に
なったとトータルで考えたらものすごい
可能性があるんですようちの会社若い時は
劣等官があったんだ
けど今僕は本当にその劣等官から解放され
ましたね完全に解放されましたそしてこの
会社ををまさに芸術作品のように仕上げて
いっ
て今年私は1つの節目うん国旗を迎える
わけだよ
ねま事実鉄鉱上の行員だった私は今
ナポレオンヒル財団のアドバイザー
リポートの一員にもなりいろんな意味で
リーダーシップの分野でそれなりに評価を
されてきているなんだろう結局でも最初は
負のエネルギーだったんだよネガティブな
負けないぞとか悔しさとか悲しさとか不安
とか恐れもエンジだったと思うでもある
ところから変わったんだよねその負の
エネルギーすらも悪いものじゃないんだ
けれどこの負のエネルギーから反射の世界
に行っちゃったり負のエネルギーから犯罪
の世界に行くとかこれは気をつけなきゃ
だめですやっぱり愛と出会ったことが
大きい29歳で僕はやっぱりバイブルの力
は僕の人生を変えたねだからシングア
グリッチの成功哲学も何のために大金持ち
になりたいのかって言ったら社会のために
大金持ちにならなきゃいけないってことに
なるわけで最初は家族を守り社員を守りた
けど最後は社会のためまただはねやっぱり
社員の将来のために考えてもっと健全な
やっぱりこう経済的な繁栄を作り出して
もっと分配をしてあげたいと将来的には
会社と一緒になって豊かになっていける
そんな理想
教ユートピアを目指したいね僕はでも
オーナーだからそれができるんだよ芸術
作品のようにそこにチャレンジしてるんだ
今だから気がついたら等感なくなったって
ことそうしたらありがとうございます中に
はやっぱそのま劣等感というかま本当に
そのもうどうせ自分なんてていう思いが強
すぎてなんかその何もできないみたいな人
もいらっしゃると思うんですけどそそれっ
てまずどうやったら行動につ成功哲学を
100回読んで
[音楽]
くださいいやマジにそしてそこに書いて
あることを実行してください私がそうした
んだからで書いてるあることを実行した
もん俺
信念という死を読んだりね昔は別に携帯
電話でなかったから今だったら携帯電話に
全部それを吹き込んだらいいよそれを
ランニングしてる時に聞いたりして自分の
思考を一心させることですそれができるの
はその人しか無理なん
です第3者は何人足りともその人を変える
ことはできません本当にこれはシビアな話
ですその人がが依存と甘えを持ってる間は
根な考え方を選び続けますそしたら貧しく
終わります貧しい年寄りになりますいや
うちの社員は220人いるけど出世する
人間出世しない人間全部分かるもん俺
220人見てなんで目指してるものが違う
からだよ時間の使い方が違う脳に入れてる
情報が違うもんそれよく見てますよ僕に
対する質問が違うでしょ
全く違います
もんやっぱりね目指してるものが違うん
ですフリータになる人はフリータになり
ます目指してるものが違うんです僕は世界
最高峰だ
から目指してるものがだからどんな現象も
全部プロセスなんだ
よここにあるんですよ理想教がそこに
向かって努力し続けるよ
[音楽]
まあさ正直さ自分という人間を大切に
できるのは自分しかいないよいいんじゃ
ない悲劇のヒロインを演じて貧乏でね
うまいものも食えなくてそこそこほどほど
の人生が好きだったらそれも人生だよ俺
ちょっとシビアだけど俺は嫌だから俺は
絶対嫌だもう子供ん時に十分味わったんだ
嫌なんです貧乏大きピッて聞いただけで吐
たき持って
ピンピンなんで俺が貧乏になんなきゃいけ
ないんだ
よ大嫌いですあといじめ
差別本当に嫌いなんです
これなんで肌の違いでいじめられなきゃ
いけないんだよてそういうのあるのよ俺
マイノリティに対する偏見とかね俺なんか
もう超マイノリティの中卒だったわけだ
から
今まに見てろと燃えよドラゴンみたいな口
から龍が出てましたぐわーまそうやって
頑張ってきたんだよ俺自分のこと大好きだ
し本当に自分のことをもう1人の自分が
マネージメントしてきまし
た頑張れ
サトお前はできる絶対できる俺がついてる
から大丈夫だもう1人の自分が自分を守っ
てきたよ
自分の理想が自分をマネージメントする
ちょっと過激なねなんか変りもんだなと
ユニークだなと思われるかもしんないけど
まあ日本を代表する能力アの
コンサルタントはこんな感じって感じま
是非ねチャンネル登録してくださいあと
コメント欄にもね色々ま本当正直ね悩ん
でる人いたら是非ねうん僕の本一生折れ
ない自信の作り方っていう本書いてますの
で昔僕がなかった時のことも書いてるんで
是非読んでください30万部を超える
ベストセラなってますからえ是非また次回
のYouTubeでお目に帰り
[音楽]
ましょうだから29歳の時に愛が分かって
選択理論に出会いま人材教育の仕事に
携わってきた42歳の時からはお金の心配
をなくても良くなって完全に解放されたの
は45ぐらいからですだ富の形成の段階
って46から60歳って言ってるんだけど
本当にその通りなった17から27までを
学習の段階28から35までを指導量開発
の段階で36から45までこれを挑戦の
段階で46から60までを富の形成の段階
で61以降を社会還元の段階と言って段階
を追った自己実現ってことを考えてきたん
だけど本当にその通りになった僕はもう
46歳から全くお金の苦労したことがない
全くないですで今気が付いたらまあ
100億をえる資産がね純資産ができて
しまって
でなんでだろうって考えたらいい組織作っ
てるからですよで良い組織の中心に何が
あるかって言ったら良い理念があるんだよ
良い目的があるんだよ良い目的に人が
集まってるんですよそしてそれを具現化
するための具体的な才能のある人間を集め
てトレーニングして組織化して価値を
作り出してってるよねそれが結果的に価値
ある商品を世の中に広めるということでま
今期おそらく70億を超えると思うんだ
けどまサービス企業でコンサルティング
会社ではそれなりの実績になってきたわけ
ですよま去年の9月の決算ではま経常力
21億とその中で税引を利益の3割は社員
に分配をする3割は内部留保3割は配当1
割は社会還元ということを2006年から
実行してるのね2005年の新卒採用を
始め時から考え出してだ若い子の立場に
立った時にどういう会社がいい会社なん
だろうって考えてそういう仕組みを整えて
いきながらやってきたわけだよね今度あの
7月かなビッグサイトで6450人の僕の
3日間の講座やろうと思ってんだよ楽しい
ね6450人経者ばかりが集まるんだよ
600人もうんでもなんでじゃ1000人
にならないのかなと思っちゃう
俺たった600人がまだと今は3450人
じゃそれが600人になって1000人に
なって最後は武道館でやるかみたいなや
兵吉だみたいないいじゃないすか最後の
最後745歳になったらやってやろうかな
と思ってるよAちゃんと一緒であと5年
ぐらいかかるわ組織作りすんのに1000
人やろうと思ったらでもそれぐらいの志し
もって日本の自己啓発市場に名を
残す1度の人生2度ない人生どう生きるか
本気で生きるも1回中途半端に生きるも1
回たった1回だ
よ人生は箱根駅伝のようにオロ袋ないオロ
だけしかないんですよ人生は俺は最後の
最後まで悔のない人生を全としますなんか
今の質問に全然答えになんない気合い
ちゃったな大丈夫
大丈夫ですうん大丈夫うんということ
ありがとうござい
[音楽]
ます決して負けない経営なんですまず経営
者自身がお金よりも仕事の内容そのものに
惚れ込んでるかどうかなんですよT
[音楽]